if anyone had any doubts of like if I'm
a piece of crap they're gonna be like oh
no she definitely is after this I feel
pretty good I have no idea what types of
questions are about to be asked but do
you know I have a lot of dating
experience like it or not farted audibly
on a first date I have not I'm gonna go
with I have not I'll do this because on
my second date with my fiancee I farted
and I'm like the pro upkeeping in farts
and it just we still add it was in like
a hotel bathroom it was like haha and I
even had to say out loud afterwards hey
I just farted and he went what I had sex
on the first date I'm gonna go with I
have again yeah the occasions that I can
think of there was at least a yeah like
there was there's a date that occurred I
never ever ever went on a date with
someone I met at a bar yes I have I feel
like that's probably the most common way
to meet someone besides than anything
else around so if I haven't because
drunk people are annoying usually I uh I
can't drink so I would say I have not
the most common way to pick up women
apparently is off limits for me I
wouldn't say so most successful way to
meet accidentally removed skin wins
right this is the wrong way when on a
blind date yeah I think if anything I've
been asked like will you quad with me
right now and like I'll quad no problem
I've not gone on a blind date but that
sounds really fun and I definitely like
to if any of my friends are watching
this and you have anyone in mind
please set me up with someone that
sounds like a amazing time to go
somewhere and it's like I have no idea
what your deal is until I get there
that's cool that would be really cool I
have not but it does I have a story
that's maybe semi-related I had a friend
that tried to set me up with a girl and
we didn't like go on the date but there
was like a thing we're like she was like
oh let me like meet with
but I think she like saw me and she just
like didn't want to bother meeting me so
that happened that's the closest thing I
could say his clothes to a blind date is
someone before the date even had been
not even wanting to see me so I got
there we go oh my god
went on a pity date because I felt bad
for the person I have it's typically
when I want to give someone like another
chance and yeah if it's like the second
date like a pity yes I don't know
whether that makes me a bad person or a
good Samaritan I can't probably have
like a second job at this point if I had
just not gone on pity dates I think it's
a guy obviously you're dating prospects
are a little different like you can't I
would say that I used to have a policy
where I was like oh go on a second date
with anyone even it was a bad day maybe
it was a bad first impression forgot the
name of the person I was out with oh boy
you're bad person and not even I wasn't
even drunk I'm high-fiving you battles
if you have to do like a refresher like
right before you walk in like while it
was happening like no I think I was like
pretty confident in what their name was
yeah and then I not it's tough because
it's like you remember the conversation
but like I don't know I'm just not
thinking of your name I know that we
talked about that you like to ride
horses and I thought that was weird
because you're 45 involving my name is
so intimate like I feel like I only say
the name where I'm like yeah like yeah
that was great
dated someone who did something serial
killer ask killer ask he's like very
broad so that's definitely and I have
yeah okay I'm gonna go with I have just
because I've definitely casually dated
like someone with sociopathic tendencies
before a little bit just like right like
just like kind of like lacking empathy
he talked about eugenics a lot curse
dead okay in a favorable way I think
there was a time where I was like okay
with any and all red flags I guess if
anything I was like oh it'll be a great
story you know even just like wild
tempers and like that inability to pause
you definitely had that too like if I
saw him all the nice things about the
surprise oh gosh
hopefully
I know like he seemed like a generally
nice guy just he could be a serial
killer if he goes down the wrong path
said I needed to use the restroom and
left I decided I needed to use the
restroom to burn time from a date
because when I figure out the plan yeah
I said I've always come back I have not
I don't think anyone has ever been like
rude enough or terrible enough for me to
do that I mean I've I've stood up mid
date and just be like this doesn't work
and walked out we've always said but
because why why am I wasting your time
am i doing like this doesn't work I'm
not into it
I don't want to do it I mean if it's a
safety thing like yeah I don't care I
will leave no matter what
if anything it was like oh actually like
sorry like I have to get going after
like 45 minutes sorry oh I'm feeling
glad that things that are in the past or
in the past most people had these
experiences you know I think dating
stuff is always so like scary for people
you automatically hear judgment but like
we don't it doesn't really matter the
amount of people how many times you do
it what you do like whatever weird
fetish like have a good time no this is
fun I'm glad now the internet knows a
lot of yeah it'll it'll be great
[Music]